>> OFFICIALS IN SRI LANKA ARE
TRYING TO HANDLE AND DISASTER
CARGO SHIP HAS BEEN BURNING IN
THE COAST FOR WEEKS NOW AND IS
EXPECTED TO SINK AT ANYTIME.
LET'S GET THE LATEST FROM ANNA
COREN STANDING IN HONG KONG.
WHAT ARE THE DETAILS?
>> JOHN THE FIRES ARE BURNING,
NOT AS INTENSE AS IT WAS BEFORE
BUT IT HAS NOW BEEN BURNING FOR
A WEEK.
THIS SINGLE POOR BASE SHIP HAS
COME FROM INDIA AND WAS LOADED
UP IN THE PORT AND WAS MAKING
ITS WAY THERE VIA COLOMBO WHERE
THEY WERE EXPERIENCING TROUBLE.
AUTHORITIES ARE SAYING THAT THE
SHIP, WHICH I SHOULD ADD IS
RATHER NEW IT'S ONLY A FEW
MONTHS OLD, HAS TRIED TO DOCK
INTO QATAR AND INDIA
COMPLAINING OF PROBLEMS WITH
WAS REFUSED TO DOCK.
IT THEN A KURD OFF THE COAST OF
CUBA, THE COAST OF COLOMBO
WHERE THERE WAS AN EXPLOSION.
THEY THOUGHT THEY HAD CONTAINED
THIS EXPLOSION AND THEN THERE
WAS ANOTHER ONE ON SHOES DAY,
AND THAT IS ONE TO MEMBERS OF
THE 25 MAN CREW WERE INJURED.
BUT EVERYBODY MANAGED TO BE
EVACUATED.
OBVIOUSLY FIREFIGHTERS ARE NOW
DESPERATELY TRYING TO PUT OUT
THIS FIRE, THEY'VE BEEN
STRUGGLING TO GET CLOSE ENOUGH
TO THE BLAZE BECAUSE OF THE
INTENSE HEAT.
BUT JOHN, YOU MENTIONED THIS
ENVIRONMENTAL DISASTER THAT IS
PENDING.
FISH SHIPPED CONTAINS OVER 1400
CONTAINERS, MANY OF THEM HAVE
FALLEN OFF, BUT THEY CONTAIN 25
TONS OF NITRIC ACID AS WELL AS
OTHER CHEMICALS.
IF THE SHIP SINKS, NOT ONLY
WILL THERE BE CHEMICALS
POTENTIALLY LOSE, IF THESE
CONTAINERS BREAK OPEN.
BUT THEY COULD ALSO BE A
MASSIVE OIL SPILL.
THERE ARE 350 TONS OF OIL ON
THE SHIP, SRI LANKAN OFFSHORE
THESE ARE WORKING DESPERATELY
TO TRY TO CONTAIN THE OIL SPILL
THAT IS ALREADY COMING FROM THE
SHIP.
SRI LANKA NORTH ALREADY SAY
THEY DON'T HAVE ENOUGH OIL
BOOMS, SO THEY'VE CALLED THE
INDIAN AUTHORITIES TO ASSIST
WITH THAT, THEY ARE SENDING
PLANES AND TUGBOATS.
OTHER VESSELS ARE TRYING TO
PREVENT WHAT UNFOLD.
THAT IS THE REAL PROBLEM THAT
IS FACING THE AUTHORITIES.
THEY DON'T KNOW WHEN THE SHIP
IS GOING TO SINK, IF IT IS
GOING TO SINK, AND IF THERE
WILL BE AN ENVIRONMENTALISTS
ASTRONAUTS A RESULT OF THAT.
JOHN?